je m'appelle i -p -e
c'est ma famille les croûtes on est dans
cette caverne
une éternité trois jours c'est pas une
éternité
ainsi avec cette famille maman maman oui
toujours
on n'avait jamais pu explorer le monde
extérieur à cause du grand préceptes de
mon père quand c'est nouveau c'est
mauvais ne jamais pas avoir peur
mais ce qu'on ne savait pas c'est que
notre monde allait bientôt changer
romain cabannes
faut vraiment que vous voyez se regarder
on y va non
où sommes nous je sais pas trop je
m'ennuie c'est ma belle gaye et lui ses
bras ses cuisiniers et causeur et
copient le trou et ceintures
accessoirement faut pas rester là c'est
la fin du monde quoi tout ce qu'il ya
autour de nous va disparaître j'appelle
ça la fin
il nous faut il qu à berne
je peux vous aider suivez moi je suis
sûr qu'on réussit à l'écrou de presse
ensemble sauf vous deux
faut avancer plus vite j'appelle ça
chaussures les adore c'est super où sont
les pieds
tous à l'intérieur et regarder cette
caverne l'eau-de-vie mia qu'est ce que
c'est que ça mais sa mort le sommet dans
les hautes herbes cas